pub
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
au cours de son voyage de cinq jours en
normandie le général de gaulle a visité
20 à vie
[Applaudissements]
dans ce discours un thème identique nous
approchons de la paix en algérie
la france veut et propose que la paix
s'établisse l'algérie décidera de son
destin et alors c'est un vote de tous
les algériens qui règlera leurs propres
problèmes
ces paroles le chef de l'état les a
répétés tout au long de 970 km de son
voyage qui a partout suscité les
ovations les plus chaleureux
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
mais c'est aussi avec des souvenirs que
le général de gaulle est allé renouer en
normandie est parmi les plus émouvants
bayou bayeux qui la cueillette au
troisième jour de son périple fut en
juin 44
la première ville française libérée
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
à rouen où s'achevait sa quatrième
journée c'est avec les installations
industrielles du grand port que le chef
de l'état devait prendre contact
[Musique]
comme à temps car ville le lendemain
avec le plus grand pont suspendu
d'europe
[Applaudissements]
mais avant la traversée du pont de
tancarville le général de gaulle avait
tenu à saluer le plus célèbre des
havrais le président rené coty
[Musique]
le havre avait été ainsi la dernière
étape du voyage un voyage triomphal
en italie le mois de juillet a mal
commencé
tout est parti du gène ou 15000
grévistes manifestaient contre la
réunion prochaine dans la ville du
congrès du parti néo fasciste
[Musique]
commencé dans le calme cette
manifestation devait se terminer en
bagarre et un peu plus tard les jeeps de
la police tentait de faire le vide dans
les rues de la ville
[Musique]
bilan de cette journée agitée 30 blessés
mais les événements de gênes devais
avoir 6 jours plus tard à rome des
prolongements plus grave encore
à tel point qu'on a pu parler d'émeutes
à propos des violences engagements qui
ont opposé dans la capitale italienne
les manifestants à la police
[Musique]
la journée qui avait été en outre
marquée par une bagarre à l'intérieur du
parlement
ce solde est cette fois par une
cinquantaine de blessés et 350
arrestations
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
le congo a eu des lendemains
d'indépendance terrible deux jours après
la proclamation de cette indépendance
les troupes congolaises intervenait
entre les tribus rivales et ses images
disque assez éloquemment que
l'atmosphère n'était pas à la douceur et
les violences devaient se tourner
ensuite contre les européens utilisent
les soldats congolais ont favorisé
l'anarchie dans le pays
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
m
à bruxelles l'angoissent saisi tous ceux
qui ont des leurs au congo on a pu voir
des groupes en larmes se former au pied
de la statue de léopold ii
le fondateur de l'état du congo
puis à l'aérodrome sont arrivés les
premiers avion ramenant de brazzaville
les premiers réfugiés des femmes et des
enfants
les mains vides abandonnant tout pour
fuir les eaux polluées certains ont
traversé le fleuve congo en pirogue
[Musique]
et les récits n'ont fait qu'accroître
l'angoissent à bruxelles
comme d'autres récits avait propagé
l'affolement à léopoldville recid
arrestations de ressortissants belges de
scènes de pillage de violence et de
sévices or quelques milliers seulement
ont pu fuir derrière eux la route de
l'exode a été coupée et léopoldville à
une seule compte plus de 20000 européen
[Musique]
l'ouverture de sa journée de la
communauté ghani a reçu de nombreuses
personnalités françaises et africaines
organisées dans les différentes villes
de france ces journées placées sous le
patronage des premiers ministres des 12
états membres ont pour but de faire
mieux connaître les aspects si divers
des pays de la communauté
[Musique]
fertilisez le sahara sereine que des
générations de prospecteurs ont caressé
devient aujourd'hui une réalité et le
plus simplement du monde dans la région
de touggourt six forages viennent de
faire jaillir à raison de 400 litres la
seconde l'eau emmagasinée à 1700 mètres
de profondeur sous le désert
cet événement presque miraculeux a été
accueillie avec la satisfaction qu'on
imagine chacun de ces nouveaux points
d'eau doit donner naissance à une
quantité de petites exploitations d'un
demi-hectare comprenant maison palmeraie
et plantations de céréales
grâce à des tours de réfrigération cette
eau qui sort à la température de 55
degrés arrive à 35 degrés dans le bassin
et devient ainsi excellente pour
l'agriculture voilà qui va révolutionner
la vie des tribus sahariennes voué
depuis des siècles nomadisme
[Musique]
voilà aussi qui vous autorise à caresser
le plus simplement du monde ce projet
devenir agriculteur au sahara
pendant 24 heures du mans c'est au pas
de course que les concurrents dès 6h
d'auvergne prennent le départ c'est
d'ailleurs là la seule analogie entre
les deux épreuves
ici le circuit étroit tourmentée pour
atteindre des vitesses qui frise le 200
à l'heure
reste à quoi bon aller si vite quand on
peut-être mire et un merveilleux
paysages pour aborder le thème épingle à
cheveux il faut peut-être mieux
cependant ne pas se laisser distraire
par le site
pas besoin de donner de conseils aux
concurrents ils ne sont ni poète ni
touristes
un poète d'entre eux c'est sûrement le
suédois bonniers puisqu'il a nettement
gagné l'épreuve au volant d'une porsche
à plus de 110 de moyenne à paris en
nocturne match et d'arrière saison au
parc des princes entre l'union
soviétique maillot foncé et la
yougoslavie les deux équipes de la
finale de la coupe d'europe des nations
finale impitoyable où les joueurs se
livrent à une lutte farouche comme s'il
y allait du sort de leur pays dans cette
rude empoignade les gardiens de but
effectué les arrêts extraordinaires
surtout le goal soviétique qui a chez
les yougoslaves meilleurs techniciens
font échec au football de combat des
soviétiques qui jouent comme de
véritables bulldozers et finalement
c'est la finesse des yougoslaves qui
l'emportent du moins momentanément il
marque en effet le premier des
soviétiques repartent en force un bolide
de l'intérieur gauche impossible à
bloquer odier droit suisse et
l'égalisation pendant de nombreuses
minutes encore puisqu'il projet la
prolongation se poursuit sous la pluie
cette gigantesque bataille de deux
équipes qui veulent gagner à tout prix
est tout aussi accrocheur tout aussi
chevelu que roger marche l'intérieur
gauche soviétique d'un défi son golgotha
de toute façon il en aura encore des
frissons à la 113e minute du match
lorsque les soviétiques de marquer le
but de la victoire
c'est surtout du dpic ils manifestent
alors que les russes sont tout à la joie
d'être les premiers champions d'europe
que ceux qui ont l'âme sensibles se
rassurent ces sports semaine néerlandais
ne sont pas de barbares chasseur de
gibier il aime le bruit des fusils mais
ils ont horreur du sang le gibier le
voilà ici pas de pigeons mais les
soucoupes volantes propulsé dans le ciel
par cet appareil bizarre encore une
cartouche les victimes
un véritable carnage après les pigeons
les lapins ce système d'entraînement à
la chasse au lièvre est absolument
inédit ce n'est pas si facile à toucher
voyez plutôt
radi cette chasse présente un avantage
on n'a pas besoin de gypse hier pour
ramener le gibier
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]